$600 million a year in meat. That's how
much Mike Salguro, the founder and CEO
of ButcherBox, sends out every single
year. And we had him fly out here to
Vegas so that we could bring this to
you, breaking it down into the tactics
of what he did to start and continue to
scale and things that any business owner
can use today to scale their businesses.
Enjoy. Before you had Butcher Box, you
had another uh business. Do you want to
do a quick like how we got here and some
of the lessons you learned from that
business, the failure? I love I love
hearing about failures. Yeah. So, I I
mean I could talk about a tremendous
amount of failure in between college and
my first business, but if if we want to
go there, but my first business was a
company called custommade.com.
And uh my best friend uh Seth and I
bought the company. Um we uh had
approached a guy to sell us
custommade.com for $140,000. Um, we
didn't have any money at the time, so we
gave him a check for $2,500 for a
deposit and then had 90 days of due
diligence, which is where you're
supposed to figure out what happens at
the company. And we took all that time
to go raise money. Um, and so we raised
500 grand. And the whole Oh, okay. Yeah.
The whole the whole thing was we were
both working in real estate and we
called it a shack in Manhattan. So this
is 2008. Uh, custommade.com got a ton of
inbound traffic. Yeah. from typing in
customade and it was filled with
woodworkers who had uh their projects
and stuff on there. And when you talk to
these woodworkers that are like, I get
all my money from custommade.com and I
pay $35 a year for my subscription
and they had to like email the owner to
like upload their content. So, we were
like, "This is like a shack in
Manhattan. We're just going to buy it.
We're going to like overhaul it." Yeah.
Turn it in they can log in and manage
their own content and jack up the rents.
sense.
Um, so people, you know, thought that
was a good idea and gave us also a great
narrative for raising money as a side
note, just even like as a shack in my
hand. Like everyone's like, "Okay, go."
Yeah. Yeah. Uh, of course, this was 2008
and in Boston in real estate and
everyone had just lost their money cuz
Bernie made off just ran off with
everyone's money. Did something happen
in 2008? Uh, United States. Yeah. I
don't know why. Okay. Crazy. Yeah. So,
uh, Bernie Maidoff ran off with
everyone's money. We heard a lot of nos,
but we cobbled together a round. Um, and
then we got going and things were
working and we raised another $500,000.
Okay. And then when you say things were
working, what did you mean? So, like you
were starting to make more like you were
able to grow the revenue of the
business. Yeah, we so we had pivoted the
website. You could now log in. We made a
ton of mistakes, but we built a sales
team. We had people calling to get
makers to sign up for like an annual
subscription or a monthly subscription.
We hit about $60,000 in revenue a month.
And what was it doing prior? Uh, $35,000
a year. Oh geez. Okay. So you c I mean
you did an amazing job. Yeah. Yeah. U
but we were still losing a little bit of
money and and whatnot. Also a great
frame for me was listening to this is
the um the idea that like um I had a
mentor say this. He's like right before
you go to take your business to market.
He's like switch sides of the table and
then try and say like you just bought
your business today. What are all the
things you'd fix about it? It's like
well maybe just do those first. And so I
think it's just a great like perspective
on any business is like if I bought
everything today, how would I it's like
a different lens at least. Anyways, for
me it's been helpful. But please
continue. Yeah. So um at the time it was
like 2010 2011 everybody in tech was
raising money. Mhm. And so we were
looking at Techrunch and looking at all
this stuff and at that time there
weren't like all these accelerator
programs and all these things that now
are exist to help people. Um and so my
co-founder and I looked at each other
we're like we have a good business. why
don't we raise money? Um and so we ran
around town again raising money this
time trying to raise from VCs and um we
got First Round Capital, which is a very
well-known VC in New York. And then we
got Google Ventures to invest in our
company at a uh it was a they we raised
1.9 million at like a 7 million. Okay.
Pre- money. Sure.
Um that's where things started like
falling apart.
So actually most people told us no. We
went to raise money and people are like
woodworker listing site like hell no and
I was in uh I was in a meeting um and at
at this VC benchmark and I said
um I was like we built this this
function this function where somebody
could post a project and makers could
see them coming in and then they could
bid on them. Mhm. And I was like, "Pull
up the job board." And this thing was
like live action. We wanted to make it
exciting. And there were like these jobs
rolling in custom coffee table, custom
I was like, "All we have to do is stand
in between these transactions and we'll
be the largest marketplace for custom
stuff." Yeah. It's 2011. As soon as I
said the word marketplace, everyone
wanted an interview. We went from no no
no to like marketplace, you could be the
next Airbnb. And we're like, "Yeah, you
bet. Yeah, sure. We can be whatever you
want. Just give us some money." Yeah.
Uh, and so we raised the money on the
premise that we were going to create a
marketplace and stand in between a
custom transaction, which wasn't the
best premise, but people loved it. Yeah.
We raised 1.9. 6 months later, there was
one VC that we left out of the first
deal. Okay. We're like, we don't want to
raise more than 1.9, so you can't
participate. Six months later, they're
like, we'll give you four on 16. We're
like, okay, we'll take more money. So,
we took four. Uh, and then we did an 18.
So now you've diluted cuz now you're at
cuz you had the 1.9 on seven. So you're
that was 20 or 2% something like that,
right? I don't know the math somewhere
in there. Uh, and then you did another
quarter so 25%. Y uh with the second
round. So you're you guys are sitting a
little bit above 50. Yep. Uh, at that
point just from the two rounds. Yeah.
Well, and then we're giving out equity
to all of our employees and all that
stuff, too. I'm highlighting this
because I I I know I think I have some
perspective on where you go. There's a
different There's a different path.
Yeah. So, and then a few years later, we
did a $10 million round on $30 million.
Um, it was actually $18 million. It was
10 of equity, four of debt, and four of
secondary. Um, okay. So, you got some
money off the table. So, we got some
money off the table. You were like
reading the tea leaves and you're like,
you know, there's no way we're going to
make anything. Yeah. We got all of our
in all of our original investors got 3x
their money if they wanted it. Many cash
out. My mother did not. She's like, "I
believe in you." Yeah. Maybe you should
cash out, Mom. But okay. She like, "I
took secondary work." Yeah. Like I I
sold.
Uh, so
um, by the end of it, I mean, what what
really happened at the company, the big
lesson I learned is um, so Google uh,
they have like incredible services for
entrepreneurs. So if you're an
entrepreneur and they invest in you,
they can help you with a whole bunch of
stuff. you want to like manage your
AdWords account, it's like go talk to
the people that run AdWords. And by the
way, here are some gift cards and like
they do all sorts of stuff to help you.
Yeah. They're like, "Do you want us to
come and look at your website and like
get under the hood of your technology?"
And we're like, "Yeah, of course,
Google. Come on in." And I I mean,
literally the guy did this like
week-long deep dive, came out, and was
like, "That's the worst website I've
ever
seen." He's like, "I can't believe we
invested in this." Like so our investors
up here, how does this even make money?
How is this like and these guys like
Yeah. And so what ended up happening
over the course so immediately we were
like we have the wrong tech team that
our investors were like you have the
wrong tech team. You have to get rid of
them. Yeah. So we got rid of our tech
team and then it was like you have the
wrong product people and then you have
to get rid of the product people. You
have the wrong marketing people. And
what ended up happening over the course
of about a year is I took all of the
people who helped me build this company
to help help me like hack through the
jungle to get to like the road and we
fired all of them. Yeah. And as one does
as and I was left with a company of um
new hires new hires people that didn't
fit the culture. I hadn't written down
the cultural values. Yeah.
And I just have this vivid memory of um
sitting in my car in the parking lot
being like I I can't go in. Like I can't
I don't even want to go to work. Yeah.
And I had like a good salary, but by
that point with all the delution I owned
like 8% of the thing which I could go
get a CEO job doing something. It was
just like this like what have I done?
Yeah. And I I I let go of all my
friends. It was it was bad. Yeah. How
many years was this? Uh eight years of
working on it. Eight years. 2015 or
sorry 2008 through 2015. So we just we
covered eight years in a pretty short
short little window just for anyone
who's listening. And I bring this up
just cuz like I feel like when when you
when you hear the stories or you watch
the the literally the 60-second short
about someone's career, um it always,
you know, you l you see the highlights
and the low lightss, but a lot of it is
just kind of like the mundane middle of
just dealing with the stress of every
day. There's always fires and there's a
per a permeating level of baseline
stress that doesn't really go away.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And so I mean one big
lesson was like don't listen to
investors when I when I started Butcher
Box which we'll get into. I didn't want
to take investment. There was also like
I lost myself. I lost my team and I lost
myself. And when I looked at the
shambles that happened um was like I
don't want to Did you shut it down?
Yeah. So, we um we actually foreclosed
on it because we had some venture debt.
There was a little bit of debt. Our bank
account got
below we owed and they were like, "We
we're we're taking it." So, we actually
did a what's called a friendly
foreclosure. They took it over. My
co-founder stayed and it's still running
it. Oh, it's still going. Yeah. Is it
doing okay? It It's now a jewelry
company and it's just they just do
everything. There's no maker. There's no
like no marketplace. The big problem
that we had was you can't like these
custom if you want a custom coffee table
or a custom piece of jewelry. There's
like 60 back and forths to like talk
about every detail like and we had to
stand in between that in order to get
our fee which was like 10%. Which is a
nightmare. It was a bad business. Yeah.
But we because we sold everyone on
marketplace when we were like this isn't
going to work. People are like well
that's what I invested in so you you
need to keep going. So doing the other
version of so because so I think about
this sometimes as like the path not
taken. So if you had if you had not
raised really any of the money besides
the amount that you needed to kind of
acquire the business. So at that point,
what did you raise the five what did you
raise the $500,000 when you did that?
You didn't go through the due diligence
that period where you raised the 500.
What was the what was the or how much
equity did you give away for that? It
was a convertible. So it converted into
the the next round like a safe round.
Yeah. Oh, great. Okay. So that ended up
being like five or six I mean well a
little more than that. So like 7% of the
business. Yeah. um which would have been
pretty a pretty good a pretty good move
effectively. Yeah. And if that business
at the time said it was doing $60,000 a
month, right? So 720 a yearish in terms
of run rate. Y if you had stuck with the
original model Mhm. and just been like
I'm not I don't have to pursue
this not as an insult but like cockamini
uh business model basically Billy or
bust business model is what I mean to
say. Um, it probably could have just
been a very profitable. I mean, going
from $35,000 a year to $60,000 a month
in like 12 months is is is great growth.
And was it was it profitable at that
point? It was almost profitable. You
could have made it if you wanted. We
could have been profitable and that's
one of the reasons why like I want to be
here today and I like talking to people
like you who talk to entrepreneurs about
a different path than raising a bunch of
money, diluting yourself, having people
who tell you what to do and losing your
culture in the meantime and losing
yourself. Every business I've had has
been bootstrapped that I've so I get it.
Yeah. So when I started Butcher Box and
so I took the we we closed the business.
We let go of 50 people. Yeah. Uh shut
the doors. I literally closed the gate
and put the lock on and then your
partner's like I'm still here though and
we're still going to keep we're going to
make Yeah. They like spun it out. And
are you guys still friends? Yeah, we
are. Oh, good. That's cool. Yeah. Uh it
was a it was a little rocky for a couple
years but uh yeah, we're good friends.
Um I took the weekend off. It was
Memorial Day weekend, so it was a long
weekend. Um, and then I started Butcher
Box, okay, on Tuesday. And, uh, I I had
known in the final year at Custom Aid,
it was very clear to me that we were
going to hit a wall and there was like
no stopping it. My co-founder had become
CEO in that last year because there was
he he just like loved the distressed he
wanted to be the What was revenue then?
Uh, so we we would only talk about GMV
because because it was platform. So, our
GMV I think got to like 3 or 4 million a
month. Okay. Uh but you know, then we
took a a 10% but actually because of I
forget all the reasons it was like 7%.
Yeah. Um so like 200 200,000 200,000 a
month. Uh we at our height were burning
500,000 a month. That is Yeah. Healthy
burn. Yeah. Healthy, right?
Just like never say anything like it.
like yeah there's a down just a road
quote from uh Reed Hoffman I think he
was talking to Elon or Peter Seal or
something and he there they were on this
the roof of of the building that they
were at for PayPal and he said if we
were one at a time lighting $100 bills
and pulling them off the building he
said it wouldn't be as fast as we're
actually burning money in this company
and like I just saw that was such a
visual of like I could burn $100 bills
slower than we're actually burning the
money in this business, which I thought
was hilarious. Yeah. No, it's wild. I
mean, you start adding a bunch of people
and then you add managers to manage
those people and then you do a bunch of
marketing and all of a sudden you're
just like losing losing money. And when
you raise, especially when you raise
something like a $18 million round, they
want you to spend the money as fast as
possible. And the thing the thing that
they don't talk about with venture is
venture capitalists get paid when they
put money out on the street. They take a
management fee. And so um they have
everyone around the table has the
incentive to like put as much money as
humanly possible into these deals. And
so you really when you go like people
are like how do I figure out what my
valuation is? It's like no no just tell
them how much money you can spend over
the next 18 to 24 months and just argue
for a bigger number. We're like we can
blow through 10 million. They're like
great here's a check. So um yeah it was
uh which is counter to how like business
works as a side note. So just so it's
interesting because you're actually it's
it's the collision of two different
business models and the one who has the
voting rights is the one who wins. Um
but like their business model is
deployment of capital and management
fees by and large. Obviously there's
carries and things like that but um
there's that component and then there's
the business model of the actual
business but the person who actually
calls the shots is the the the largest
business the person who makes the most
money from the business prevails in
terms of um who has leverage in in the
conversation. Yeah. And we had all the
rights. So we negotiated really really
well. We had all the rights in our
documents. U my my co-founder Seth was
just like a phenom at that. So they
couldn't overthrow us. They didn't have
any management decisions etc. But it
doesn't matter like at the end of the
day when they're like you're going to be
black balled if you don't like the
pressure, you know. Um so at the end it
was like we're going to sell the
company, we're going to bring in a
different CEO, we're going to do all
these things. None of which worked.
Yeah. Um, I knew the writing was on the
wall and so I'd been playing around with
like a like what am I going to do next?
And I had a few ideas. Um, I had a
billboard company I was really
interested in starting. I had a bond
company I was really interesting in
starting and I had this like shipping
meat in the mail. Interesting. Um, and
uh, the quick backstory, uh, my wife has
an autoimmune uh, disorder. We were
following these elimination diets to
like clean up our diet. We were trying
to find grass-fed beef. Couldn't find
it. Huh. Okay. Um and I just got
obsessed with like where do you find
grass-fed beef? Yeah. And why is this a
hard thing to find? Yeah. Why is this
hard to find? And I ended up like
meeting a farmer in a parking lot and
buying trash bags full of meat and being
like this is weird. Um and I started
selling steaks to my buddies because I
it was like too much meat. Yeah. And one
of my buddies was like, "This would be
so much easier if it was delivered to my
house." Yeah. I don't want to like meet
you at your house to pick up the the
meat in a like just ship it to my house.
And so I was like, "Okay, how do you
ship meat in the mail?" Yeah. I couldn't
figure it out. This is all while I was
like still at Custom Made. Um and then I
met This is while you were at Custom
Mate. Well, it was like at the tail end.
You were having an affair. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Uh things were closing down. Um
then I reached out to the former head of
operations of Omaha Stakes, which at the
time was like the big meet the mail
company. And he's like, "Yeah, like I my
non-competes over." Oh, great. Uh I can
help you. That's amazing. And so he made
all these introductions. Yeah. Pro tip
right here just for everyone listening.
Uh find the person who has built the
business. Yes. Uh already like it's you
know um from an entrepreneur perspective
I think in the beginning is always about
how like all you know you're very tactic
obsessed and obviously I talk a lot a
lot about tactic stuff on this channel
but um I say beyond a certain point it
just becomes a lot about who because the
leverage is in not having to live the 15
or 20 years or however long this guy had
been in the in the stake business.
You're like, you can either like relive
his life and then be 20 years older.
It's like or you can just find that guy
and then he doesn't have to live your
life either and then you combine and
everybody wins. And so I think in the
earlier stages of my career, I I I
thought way more what and how than who.
Yeah. Um also the way that I structured
it, so I had a whiteboard, I had the
three ideas and I had like the kill shot
like the thing that if I didn't figure
out this week or this month, like it you
don't have a business. So, for the bomb
thing, it was like a legal thing. And
for the um for for Butcher Box, it was
like, "How do you ship this?" Yeah. And
so, I actually like every time I went to
the bathroom, I'd be like, "All right,
how do you ship me?" You know, like
reaching out to people, trying to get
somebody to to help. He finally said
yes. Um and so fast forward to close the
doors at ButcherBox or sorry, at uh
Customade and it was pretty clear that
like why don't I just like spend the
summer messing around with this idea?
Mhm.
So, my intention was to build a hobby
business. Like, I was I was very
enamored by like Tim Farah's 4-hour work
week. Like, you know, build something
that runs in the background and then you
can go live your life, you know, uh
passive income. Um, and uh that was like
I I thought if we had a thousand
subscribers and we made a $20 profit on
each subscriber, it's $20,000. you. So
if you customer service, if you
outsource that and if you build tech
easy, like you could have like $10,000 a
month.
Um and so I built it was like WordPress
on top of Stripe, which nowadays there's
Shopify, which is incredible, but like
WordPress on top of Stripe, which um uh
we basically ran with until last year
when we moved to Shopify. And then we
outsourced everything and it was like,
okay, this is going to be a hobby
business.
And the first thing I did, so I I had I
had an intern start with me on like I
want to pause us on something because I
think it's such an important thing. So
like I have I have had such a similar
experience to I think the what you just
walked through from a narrative
perspective, which is that every time
I've tried to like build a business, it
doesn't work for me. It hasn't. And I've
failed a bunch of times on businesses
that I was like, I'm building a
business. when I was like, how do I make
some money that doesn't take a ton of my
time? I end up building a really good
business. Yeah. And so, it's just like
an again, it's these like these these
frames of questions and I think this at
any level you could ask it from a
product line perspective or a new
division perspective, but it's it's like
I have I've had these like romantic
ideas of like this big thing that I want
to have happen rather than
like, you know, I just I just want to
make some money in a really easy way.
And then when what's interesting though
is that you're basically sol I call it
solving for zero which is like how do I
solve for like no time and profit. But
when you solve that problem when you
have no time and profit it also scales a
lot easier because you already started
with the premise of how do I have it put
no time not be as risky and be
profitable. Sorry, pick back up. Yeah.
No, that's right. Um if you build
something to be a hobby, it can remain a
hobby. Um and I could I'll talk about
our backbone now, but it's it's very
similar. Everything is third party. Um
we have really tight specs on
everything. But we took the perspective
uh that um I start I started with I want
a hobby and nowadays I took the
perspective of like we're not going to
learn how to ship boxes better than a a
company that's been in the business for
75 years. Like why bother trying to do
that? So anyway, we started with an
intern uh and we decided that we were
going to do a Kickstarter campaign.
Okay. Or is Kickstarter or Indiegogo at
the time? Yeah, this is 2015. Also,
different way of raising money, by the
way, for everyone who's listening.
Pre-sales, though. Yeah. So, it's not
raising money. You're just selling your
product and you're seeing if there's a
market and you're getting money up
front. Every one of my So, my first gym,
I saved all my money to start as soon as
I and I and I wanted to start the gym as
fast as humanly possible because I
thought if I started the gym really
quickly, then I could start making
money. every gym after that gym, I had
multi-month pre-sales that would pay for
the that would finance the entirety of
the gym off of people pre-bying
memberships and pre- buying weight loss
challenges and things. And so, like,
this is definitely like a 101 to 2011
entrepreneur. Like, the first one, you
know, you're you're taking the outside
capital. You're like, you know, I'll bet
you I could just get my customers Yeah.
to just pay on different payment terms
and just get and then it's also also a
great uh product market fit test. If no
one wants to buy your pre-sale, then
thank god you didn't like raise money
for it or something like that. as like
we actually know people want to buy it
and they're willing to pay for it and
wait. Yep. Exactly. That's the great
thing about Kickstarter is people are
used to waiting a really long time um to
get their products. Uh and and you know,
we basically started we we hadn't
launched yet, but we went out and showed
our page to people. And the first thing
that we learned was people were like, "I
don't need that much beef. We only have
grass-fed beef." Right. We're trying to
sell people 8 to10 pounds of grass-fed
beef for $129. People are like, "I don't
need that much beef. I would never buy
this." Yeah. And we're like, "Well, what
if we put in chicken and pork as well?"
They're like, "Oh, totally. Can you make
it at the same standard? Like, can you
find chicken that's like raised better
and pork that's raised better?" And
we're like, "Yeah, to." So, we we
started with a box uh beef chicken or
pork and launched our Kickstarter. And I
think one of the, you know, one of the
things that we've done well as a company
is found arbitrage opportunities. Yeah.
Yeah. And so, the first arbitrage
opportunity was with Kickstarter. Okay.
Um, so back in 2015, Kickstarter had
this verified badge. Mhm. Like if if it
would be like Kickstarter verified. Mh.
And so what we did is we watched uh
these campaigns and to see like which
campaigns got the verified badge and
then tried to reverse engineer like how
did they get the verified badge and it
was one part early momentum, you know,
sales coming in. I tried to reach out to
all the founders and be like, oh, we're
doing this thing. I did whatever it
took. Um, and so we went out to raise
25,000 in pre or in sales. Preed, right?
And, uh, we ended up raising we ended up
selling 40,000 in boxes in the first
day. Oh, jeez. And then we got the
Kickstarter verified badge. And then we
ended up doing 210,000 in pre-sales.
Yeah. Which
was,00 of uh, meat. Yeah. um going, you
know, the first the beauty of
Kickstarter is if you get that verified
badge, it's no longer uh you're no
longer just asking your friends and your
audience to shop. It like goes to every
push it out. Yeah. And so it was a lot
of random people we didn't know.
So um and my whole idea because I wanted
a hobby business and I didn't want to
raise money. What benefit? Just I want
to double click on the offer real quick.
Offer is part of what we talk about. So
what ancillary benefits or bonuses did
you give to people beyond just the
boxing? Was there anything else that
they got for being, you know, early
participant? Yeah, good one. Uh, so, uh,
we offered the the way that you do with
Kickstarter is, um, you try to activate
the people who have bought to like go be
your ambassadors. So, we said if we hit
$100,000 in sales, we'll get give
everyone free bacon in their first box.
Okay. Yeah. And that like people went
crazy. They're like, "I want the bacon."
You know, and started like promoting it,
putting it on their Facebook pages, all
of that. Okay. That was it though. That
was the offer. Our product, she had a
referral bonus. Yeah. Really
interesting. Um, our product was really
hard is still really hard to find. Yeah.
So, we're dealing with people who like
want to eat healthier, feel guilty about
the meat that they're eating, and we
give them an answer to that. And so,
there was it was really clear that we
had struck a nerve really quickly. Yeah.
Um, and so then during the Kickstarter
campaign, so we signed up like,00 people
during the Kickstarter campaign, the
most interesting thing that happened was
there was a we were like writing on
Twitter to anyone who did Kickstart like
anyone who talked about grass-fed beef
to get them to talk about us and this
one nutritionist. Um, so you're like
you're reaching out to them. So yeah,
just like we're doing this thing. This
is warm outreach or sorry, this is cold
outreach to uh affiliates fundamentally
uh that you'd either pay for through
sponsorships with money or free stuff or
both. Um and then I don't know if you
gave them affiliate links or it was just
like hey just talk about our thing. At
this point it was just talk about our
thing. So like I'll send you a free box
of meat if you just talk about it kind
of thing. Yeah. Um a great way to get
started early from a from a capital
perspective. So it's like both of the
examples that Mike talked about. first
is like, okay, if there's platforms that
will give you free reach, figure out
what you have, you know, reverse
engineer what free reach looks like and
they're just getting you customers for
free. And I think some people,
especially, this is weird, but like a
lot of small business owners will like
obsess about like they charge 10%. It's
like they charge a commission on
customers they get you for free, right?
What are we talking about? you know. Um,
and then with the uh affiliates and and
influencers that that you reached out
to, another way to basically like if you
if you factor in the cost, it's like
literally just the hard cost of the box
of meat is your advertising cost and
everything above that is basically
freebie. Yeah. Right. And so both of
these are super low capital ways uh
early on to to to get those initial
sales going. Sorry. Yeah. So, um, this,
uh, nutritionist in California, this guy
Chris Cresser, tweeted like, "This is an
interesting, you know, I've told you to
eat grass-fed beef. This is an
interesting place to get it." That's all
he did. Um, and we saw a flurry of
activity from that. And by flurry, I
mean, there was like seven people who
signed up. But at the time, that was
like, holy, like, what what just
happened? Yeah. And then we were like,
you know, to what you were just talking
about, we're like, we need to do more of
that. like we're we need to go find
every influencer who's ever talked about
grass-fed beef and get them to promote
promote us. So, if you're paying careful
attention, Mike is at the third step in
the scaling road map, which is
advertise. He's single person. He's the
doer and he's got a bunch of
freelancers, right? The biggest issue
he's dealing with is inconsistently
flowing. He doesn't have enough money
for tech. And so, that's the problems of
this stage. And so, if he wants to solve
them, which he obviously did, uh you
just go over to the graduate column and
do those actions. But the cool thing is
that no matter where your business is
at, you will be at one of these stages
of scaling. And if you would like my
team to personalize a roadmap
specifically for you so that we can
identify once you in for some
information which stage you're at and
send you the exact solutions of where
you are to get to where you want to go.
So all you got to go to
acquisition.com/roadmap, plug in
information, and then we'll send it
right out to you. Uh it's one of the
most valuable things I can I can give
you. So enjoy. So we finished the
Kickstarter uh and then we immediately
and that was a CTA. So when you're
pushing out to them saying, "Hey,
promote our Kickstarter basically and
they could send their traffic to your
Kickstarter to to you know the seven
buyers that came in from that from the
guy who did." Is that how that's how the
money came in? Uh yeah. Well, so
Kickstarter will tell you like where
like where did this come from? So it
came from Twitter. So we're talking But
that was but you were still in pre-sale
mode for this whole thing. Yeah. Okay.
Great.
Um Okay. So I'm going back to an earlier
point because we wanted to be capital
efficient. Uh the whole idea was we're
going to send you the butcher
selections. Okay. So it I didn't want to
hold inventory because I don't know how
many ribe eyes we're going to sell and
this is really expensive inventory. So
the idea was we'll sell a bunch of stuff
and then we'll just decide what to put
in the box. Yeah. So we sold a bunch of
stuff and then it was like okay we have
1100 boxes. We talked to the the place
that we were working with. They created
you know these different Did they have
all types of meat? The one place they
went they did. So Wow. That was
fortunate. Yeah. We started working with
this company in Wisconsin that did they
had a cutting facility and a pickpack
ship facility. It was like they did
everything. So they just had it and they
had no marketing basically. Yeah. Great.
Yeah. Okay. Um and so we we shipped out
all these boxes. Yeah. And then called
every we shipped them out really
quickly. It was like a week. Um they
were thrown for Kickstarter. Yeah.
They're like, "Wow, I got my box
already." And then we called them. Hey,
how are things going? Do you need any
recipes? Would you like to become a
subscriber? Yeah. and signed up like 40%
of the people. Amazing. So, right away
we had like, you know, Well, you didn't
just send an email to,00 people.
Wouldn't that have been easier? Nope. We
had a guy Nikki Graham who picked up the
phone and just like pounded the phone
and uh he was like $10 an hour plus like
a $5 spiff. I just want to I just want
to hit on this just cuz like these
what's nice is that you're hitting all
these really clear milestones that I
feel like are just forgotten. um which
is like just the elbow grease of what
I'll consider like unscalable work or
unscalable effort is like a lot of times
early on everyone's looking for like I
don't know if that scales. Yeah. Um it's
like well I mean you know we uh we hand
wrote you know 1,100 cards and we
manually reached out to every single
person and we had conversations with
them and we asked them if they knew
anybody else who'd be interested just
like the basics that everyone's like oh
I'm sure that would work. It's like
right but it would just be work. Yeah.
Um and you did it and obviously it
worked. Yeah. Well, and one thing that I
think is important is I knew that I
couldn't do that. Yeah. Like if you put
me in a room with a phone and said,
"Call 1100 people." No way. Like the
business wouldn't have gone anywhere.
And so it's good to know what you're
good at and what you're not good at,
what you're willing to do, what you're
not willing to do, and invest in the
areas that you're not willing to do
because if you believe in the business,
you there's a guy who for $10 an hour is
just like, "Okay, just Yeah. He's
thrilled. Yeah. And he was good at it
and like then I didn't have to do it.
But I think too often entrepreneurs um
take the approach of like they need to
do everything. Yeah. And like I mean the
business would not exist if we hadn't
made those phone calls, but if it was up
to me, I would never make those phone
calls. Was there an offer that you gave
them for the subscription? The 40%
besides like, hey, want to sign up?
I don't remember. like get your next box
for $10 off your next box or you get the
you get bacon for free in your next box
if you subscribe. There must have been
but I don't I don't actually remember.
Um but what did happen was we launched
uh
butcherbox.com. So in the background we
signed up these people and we we
realized affiliates was a thing. So we
you know started working on that. We
launched butcherbox.com to the world and
there were many people who were trying
to get in on the Kickstarter and they
let you put up a link. So they were
coming to our website and they were
buying. So right away we signed up like
five subscribers, 10 subscribers like on
the first day. Yeah. And what happened
was um we had a little tech issue. So
when those new subscribers signed up uh
they got free bacon in their first box
because we built the tech to be like
bacon's going in every first box. Yeah.
And two weeks in I get a call from the
tech guys. They're like we have a really
bad problem on our hands. I was like
what what's going on? And they're like,
"We've been sending bacon to everybody."
And I was like, "Oh my god, this is
bad." And then uh my marketing guy was
like, "Why don't we just tell people
sign up and get free bacon?" Yeah. And
it was like, "Oh, well, we can't shut it
off anyway. Let's do that." The thing's
broken. Yeah. It's broken. Like we can't
fix it. So, we're just going to That
became the That became the Because I
know that one. And like I knew that
before I even had like heard or met you
or heard the story from Harley and
whatnot. Um, so I again like Grand Slam
offers like and and you know the free
box of bacon like I I've heard of that.
Um, and so started with get bacon in
your box and then uh two years in we
created this bacon for life offer. Yes.
And that really took off. That was like
that was a ripper. Um
uh so you just oneuped an already really
good offer and said not only do you get
it in the first box, you'll get it in
every box as long as you stay
subscribed. as long as you stay a
subscriber and you know ultimately the
bacon costs $4 and the box you know
you're making your profit off of. So
it's like you're it's not that big of a
deal. Um and you definitely acquire
customers for less than four like the
arbitrage on CAC or you know CPA
depending on what industry you're in.
Yeah. Uh cost to acquire customer
significantly higher by basically said
differently if you add bacon for life in
your cost to acquire a customer drops by
more than the cost of the bacon. Uh more
importantly they stayed longer. Really?
Yeah. Oh, because now you have your free
bacon. You don't want to get rid of your
free bacon. And so they can't come back.
Well, they you now you can't if you if
you if you quit, uh you lose your for
life offers. But we have that we've
built a whole thing around these for
life offers. Our our our top people have
been with us from the beginning have
like six or seven for life offers that
they get every month. They're like, why
would I ever go anywhere else to buy my
meat? Like I'm I have all these for
life. Okay, talk to me more about this
because it's really interesting. So, how
can they stack multiple for life offer?
Like, if I'm one of the 40%, right? So,
I signed up on my subscription and I
still have the tech malfunction. So, I
get free bacon every month. Okay. How am
I getting these other ones? Well, so
pretty soon after, I mean, this is
several years in. This was like, you
know, we're fast forwarding like five or
six years. We started offering like,
okay, free bacon for life is kind of
getting overused. Let's try ground beef
for life. Okay. And then people were
signing up on ground beef for life. M
But then our customers, our current
customers are like, "What the hell?"
Like, "I want ground beef for life." So
then we just started selling ground beef
for life to our customers. So we're
like, "Okay, for $50 we'll sell you
ground Yeah. ground beef for life."
So we just stacked all of these like
offers on top of each other. Um very few
people. your gross margins went down on
some of those people, but like they
never they're just never they're just
the base that just like never and we've
gotten smarter at being like it's for a
year for life and it's like we've gotten
a lot smarter and you lose them if you
leave and like but um yeah, bacon bacon
really built this we built this business
on bacon. Um, so, uh, the the there's
one one channel. Well, I'll just say,
yeah, there's the influencer channel,
which we'll we can talk about. The other
thing that So, was it went Kickstarter
arbitrage, influencer arbitrage, and
then Facebook video arbitrage. Okay. So,
I want to talk about I'm guessing paid
ads became the next like Yes. after
influencer. Yeah. So, how did you do
influ? So, okay. I'm I'm going to
retrace the steps real quick. So, we had
Kickstarter and then uh then you
officially opened the site. Kickstarter
had a backlink to you so people would go
to the Kickstarter cuz they had good SEO
and good rankings, whatever. And
suddenly they'd find you. You started
getting sales every day. You have your
mess up on bacon, but you're like, you
know what, screw it. Let's give
everybody bacon. Um and so the
influencer strategy worked well for the
Kickstarter. So, you kind of double down
on that and say, "How do we get every
influencer on the planet to talk about
Butcher Box?" Yes, that was So, did you
go like Instagram, Twitter, like you
just went across the different channels
for influencers? No. So what we did was
we figured out that there's a company
Thrive Market. Um they're a big like
online um Thrive had done this um had
done this thing where they they had all
these influencers and they they gave a
lot of them equity. Okay. In the company
to like actively promote interesting.
They were like kind of the first ones to
unlock influencers. Okay. And so first
we reached out to like everyone who
mentioned grass-fed beef. Sure. And then
we realized that there's like a lot more
people in health and wellness. And so we
uh like Thrive Market's URL was like
slashpartner slash one. Okay. And then
slash two slash3. And so we just like
concatenated all the URLs and just like
took every single person and then found
their website and their contact
information. Oh, so you didn't go to
Thrive, you just reverse engineered
Thrive. We reverse engineered all their
influencers. Got a got a lead list of
400 people. And then like I I think
you'll like this part like cuz it I like
that part. The offer. That's a good one.
That's a good way to get your warm
leads. How I got my first leads for gym
launch was um paid a VA to go to
CrossFit's website. Sorry, CrossFit. Um
and literally look up every single uh
affiliate that affiliate box that they
had. Yep. And so because and gym owners
usually put their personal cell phone
numbers, their personal email as their
actual like thing on the on the CrossFit
site, but they wanted to get listed
because they're paying $3,000 a year to
get the listing of saying I'm an
official CrossFit, right? But for me, I
got like at the time, this is super
early, you know? We had like 1,600 names
on this list, but it was enough for
Facebook to make a look audience off of
that. And that single lookike audience
is like what built Gym Launch. Like I
didn't like I tried to hit all these
different audiences and nothing worked.
And as soon as I hit the ads to that
audience, it was like ding ding ding.
And I was like, "Oh my god, this works."
And so you reverse engineered your list.
Also
elbow grease for both of these, right?
Like you just looked at the site, looked
at the directories, and manually like
paste the stuff over. Yeah. But again,
you know, like you used a VA. I used a
VA as well. I used somebody in the
Philippines who for like 20 cents a
record, it's just like here you go. And
you sleep and it's like there the next
day. Exactly. So the way that we reached
out to these influencers I thought was
pretty genius. So we had this box,
right? We're shipping a box of meat and
at the time there was like Blue Apron,
HelloFresh and all these companies and
they all even No, Blue Apron's gone,
right? Or they're uh 2015 they were hot.
Yeah. Yeah, I remember that. Yeah. Uh
Blue Apron is now was purchased by Mark
Lori who um did Jet.com and they're
trying to like make something. Um and
then HelloFresh was a darling a little
later than that. And HelloFresh is still
around there. Okay. Yeah. I'm not. Um,
so, uh, at the time, Blue Apron and
HelloFresh would include a recipe in the
box. Okay. And our customers were like,
"This is really great, but I'd love a
recipe." Yeah. And so, what we did is we
reached out to these influencers and
we're like, "Hey, we started this
company on grass-fed beef because we
believed in like eating grass-fed beef
and you tal you've talked about
grass-fed beef and but we didn't see a
source of where to buy it. So, we'd like
to be that source." Okay. And by the
way, we're shipping out all these boxes
and we don't have any recipes. And what
we'd like to do is include your recipe
on and the VA would like, you know, find
Taco Bell. Yeah. Yeah. Steak, whatever.
And we we'd love to include that in our
box. And so these influencers who like
trade on influence are like, "Of course.
Yeah, use my recipe. No problem. Are you
going to like link to my website and all
that stuff?" We're like, "Yeah, yeah."
They're like, "By the way, what's
Butcher Box?" And we're like, "Perfect.
Let's talk."
So that was like that was like we called
it the Trojan horse. It was like not
only do you get the recipes for free,
but you also get, you know, you get in
contact with all these you get them to
reply to you. And as soon as they reply
to us, then it was like, let's talk
about Budget Box. So I I want to double
click on that real quick. So if you're
dealing with influencers, you have to
think about the currency they care about
most. And a lot of influencers care more
about fame than they do about money.
Yep. And so you were able to deal in the
currency they preferred. Yep. That's
right. Yeah. So just as like for any any
business it's like is there a way that
we can do this that's that's realist
that like actually provides real value
to them in the way that they want to get
value which I think is actually like a
really brilliant like little nugget.
Yeah.
Um okay so this is 2016 so this is a
long time ago. Yeah. At the time the
influencers especially in the health and
wellness space like didn't really know
their value. Yeah. Um and so we were
able to go to those influencers and say
look like we don't have any money. We
can't pay you upfront. I'm not paying
you like $5,000 to send an email. What
we can do is we'll pay you $10 or $15
per subscriber for every month that they
remain a subscriber. So, for life. Yeah,
that's great. Um, bacon for life. Yeah,
commissions for life. For missions,
commissions for life. And, uh, people
said yes. They started, "Yeah, I'll do
that. I'll do that." And so, we figured
out that, you know, um, tweets didn't
work, Facebook posts didn't work. The
thing that worked was a dedicated email
blast where they would be like, "Here's
Butcher Box. Let me introduce this to
you." And then ideally with a last
chance, like a last chance thing, and
there was always an offer, $20 off, free
bacon, whatever it was. And because
we're only paying these influencers $10
or $15 a month, um, we could do all of
this and be box one profitable, meaning
we still made money because we started
with a $20 profit. We still made money
on that first box. M or at least it was
like we made a penny is the is the So I
want let's talk about now that we're
here let's talk about the box economics.
So you're profitable on box one which if
we're juxtaposing this with uh
custommade right um I I always fundament
like there are some business it's
basically I think there are
significantly fewer businesses that
actually rely on outside capital to to
work than people like if you want to
build rockets it's probably yeah tough
right like you probably have to do that
but so I see a lot of businesses that
like even that that hit me up and
they're like hey you know I'm raising
capital for my insert normal business
and I'm like, have you considered just
making money? Um, no, but like real,
right? It's just like the perspective,
right? And so, um, box when you're
profitable. So, walk me through like
what the the standard box like that most
people, you know, uh, uh, what the cost
is and and all the cost associated, I
know you really obsess about the box.
Yeah. Yeah. So, um, the Omaha Stakes guy
who introduced us to the place in
Wisconsin that we worked with, which
massive by the way, the one nug Yeah.
Like opened the whole business. That's
why I was like, I need to start now. Um,
the one nugget he left me with, he's
like, "Listen, all we care about at
Omaha Stakes is dollars per box." I was
like, "What does that mean?" He means
everyone at the company knows when a box
comes off the line, how much money are
we making off the box? And so that's how
I built the business. I started the
business, right? So we were charging
$129. We were trying to make a $20
profit. We were only shipping from
Wisconsin, which is a nightmare for
California, but it was like, so we were
losing money on California, but we're
like whatever. It averaged out to 20.
Um, and it kept our focus. So, like when
I And when I talk about $20 a box, I
mean like all in because we put all the
costs associated with it in. Yeah. So,
you like fully loaded the box in terms
of cost. So, it's $20 net profit. Yeah.
Rather than gross profit per box. Uh, or
you saying gross profit? Gross profit.
Okay. Got it. Because we again it was
hobby business. So like it wasn't our
labor. It wasn't our So this is uh pickp
pack. So like putting all the stuff in
from our distribution center into a box,
the cost of the meat, uh the cost of the
box, the cost to ship the box, the cost
of the dry ice that goes in the box, uh
the credit card processing fees, the
tape that goes on the box, like all of
those things. Uhhuh.
Um, and because we we just became
doggedly focused on dollars per box. And
what I love about this business even to
this day is that we we get to focus on
like, you know, the minutia like like
negotiating the price of tape. Yeah. And
the super creative like how are we going
to get our next, you know, 500,000
customers. Um, and we get to do both.
But, uh, it we we just started with a
DNA of like we're going to negotiate
every single line item in this box. So,
what is the gross margin percentage per
box currently or that? Yeah. Oh, well,
both. Sure. Uh, like 30% is a is a
healthy gross margin. Okay. Yeah, we we
definitely want to be around or above
30%. Got it. Uh, one of the challenges
that we have as a business is that uh at
least currently. So, we're looking at
pricing model change. Currently, you pay
$169 and you choose six items in the
box. Okay? And so it's kind of an
inflationary disaster because the prices
of meat fluctuate all the time. So if
you stack it with ribe eyes, you're way
less than a a 30% gross margin. If you
stack it with really cheap stuff, you're
way more than a 30% gross margin. That's
an area where um I feel like we're in
like not in alignment with our customer.
So I want to change that over time.
Yeah. Uh but yeah, currently we're
looking at a 30%. So what are NIT
margins? They're like six. Okay. Yeah.
Got it. Got it. We did like six and a
half last year.
Certainly not a content business. It's
very different. Yeah. Different. Yeah.
Yeah. Wait, you six and a half what?
Million. Oh, yeah. Percent. I was like
that is a Okay. That was that was that's
making sure and you did and the big the
big line item. So, um these businesses
like I've seen so many of them. Uh 30%
gross margin. Yeah. Um you got 10% to
operate the place. That's salaries. Uh
technology. So a third goes to ops of
your gross margin. Yeah. Uh and then you
got 20% left over for marketing. And I
like or in profit, right? And so uh
these businesses at scale, what they do,
what you do is you market market market
for years, build your name and then just
try to collapse your marketing and take
it all in and hopefully get enough word
of mouth. Yeah. You know, from from
those customers that it can at least uh
stave off turn. Yeah, that's the like
the CPG playbook. Um, and that's what a
lot of these companies are doing. It's a
tough business. It is a tough business.
Like it's I mean in it's so it's
interesting because in so many ways it's
like software. Y um with the exception
of like rather than dealing with
development, you're dealing with supply
chain. That's your big like as a like
I'm I know there's more fires, but like
if I had if I had to simplify into like
the big buckets most of the time, I feel
like that's where um Well, why don't you
tell me? Oh, that that's Yeah. No, I I I
agree. I mean, so um you know, that was
Blue Apron's whole thing. They raised a
whole bunch of money and it was all like
we're we should be valued at a software
multiple. Yeah. Nowadays, box
subscription companies are not valued as
software multiple because there's like
actual physical product being sold.
Yeah. Um their stick is as high um as
like a I don't know well a consumer you
know consumer tech company like Shopify
for example, they have 60% annual uh
retention for like new new customers,
right? Um, I would imagine that if if
that in the consumables business that
that would be unbelievably good. Yeah.
Yeah. What's your retention on like a
year one customer?
Gosh, it's not how we look at it. Okay.
Interesting. Yeah.
Uh, it's probably around 60%. Yeah. And
that's like best I mean that's those are
like best-in-class numbers. I mean
there's a reason that you're doing Yeah.
Yeah. Is it 600 now that you guys are
doing? Yeah. Well, it's like 550. Okay.
Um, yeah. Yeah, the 600 has been out
there, but it's really 550. Uh, so yeah,
we're you have 550 million um profitable
since day one. Um, and you own 70%.
Yeah. So I, uh, I gave equity to most
employees like early on. And then Yeah,
like a software company, like a
venture-backed one. I was like, "Oh,
this is what you do. You give out
equity." Um, which uh, are you happy
about that?
In in many ways, yes. like the people
who helped me build this business, the
people who helped me hack through the
jungle um are all millionaires. Um and
you know that's cool. That's like really
neat. Uh but also we have
um it if you don't want to raise money
Yeah. which I don't and you don't want
to go public which I don't and you don't
want to sell, which I don't. It's like
how do you cash people out? Yeah. Right.
Um that has been that is a a a concern
of mine all the time is like so every
year we've actually done a uh we've
taken profits and repurchase shares so
that people have valve and so then you
basically set the valuation every year.
Yep. Okay. Yeah. Actually we do Yeah. We
there's a there's a 409a value somebody
comes in and does a valuation. We also
have done this thing which is I I don't
know if your listeners are interested
but we we've done this thing this year
which is a reverse Dutch auction. Okay.
So we like we're going to allocate this
much money to buy shares and then we
people can say what they're willing to
sell at and then we we bought them that
way which is pretty interesting. That's
awesome. Yeah. Um that's very
interesting. Yeah. It's a really it's
it's actually more common now. Um, and
it's a really great way to get like what
the actual market value is cuz when you
do evaluation, it's like not dude who
makes it up. Who knows? So during co co
was we grew the business tremendously
and we almost shut off marketing. So I
mean we just made so much profit and
then we bought all these shares and we
just started buying and buying and
buying. But then inflation took over and
so our inflationary disaster like our
margins just got super compressed. So,
we went from like a 30% gross margin to
a 25% gross margin after doing two price
increases after. Jeez. So, it was like
there was no money. Um, and we never
like ran out of money, but you know,
we're all looking around being like,
"Dude, we just like did a share buyback
like for 20 or $30 million over the past
like three years. I'd really love that
money right now." Yeah, that'd be nice.
Like, hey, can I uh Yeah. No Indian. Do
you want some shares? All right. Well,
did you so with So, this is this is a
great follow-up question. So, um do you
take regular distributions from the
company or have you just been like kind
of like you took once or twice and
that's like my you know my family set
and now everything's still like me
personally. Yeah. Yeah. Um I take uh a
salary. Okay. Um and a bonus and then um
very early on because we started as an
LLC
um I I owned all of the technology and
employed everybody. Okay. And the
company bought that from me. Got it. And
so there's been distributions to cover
that. And you control both companies. So
you have to pick what that was valued
at. Uh that had to be third party. Oh,
was it? Okay. Got to be fair to the
shareholders, but it's not all you,
right? Exactly. Yeah. Okay. Um Yeah. So
So when you've been doing the buybacks,
um were you at like 50/50 and then over
time you've kind of like bought your way
back to 7030 or Yeah, I think I think
Yeah, I think it was like 60 and now
it's Well, originally Yeah. the uh the
Omaha stakes guy and there was also a
brand guy. They this my biggest mistake
when I started the company after after
failing at custom made was I value the
company at a stupidly low rate. Okay.
And so I had just raised $10 million on
a $30 million valuation. I started this
and I'm like it's going to be a hobby.
This isn't going to be anything. So the
Omaha Stakes guy is like I can make all
these connections. I can do all this
stuff and it's uh $75,000 worth of work.
And I'm like, well, I don't have that,
so I'll give you equity. And he's like,
okay, great. How much is the company
worth? I was like, 750 grand. So, he
took 10% of the company. So, he's he's a
10% stakeholder. Not anymore. I bought
him out. Uh, and then there was a brand
guy, which was the same thing. 10% of
the company. And as we got going, I was
like, ah, that that's like way too much.
And they're not doing anything, right?
Yeah. Yeah. They did one time work. It's
like onetime work, right? Uh, and so we
bought them out. We bought them out when
the valuation was 48 million. Well, I'm
sure they were thrilled. And it was
Yeah. two They got $200,000 a month for
two years. Okay. Um I'm sure he was
still thrilled, you know, right?
Probably more than he made at Omaha.
Totally. Yeah. Way more. Um one one good
phone call for him. Yep. Right. A little
bit of work. Yeah. Yeah. Except for
life. Interesting. So, okay. So,
man, there's so many directions I want
to go, but uh to to to put a button on
on on the story and then I want to go
back and kind of unpack some numbers and
things like that. Um where do you want
to so where do you want to
if you're not going to IPO? Y and you're
not going to sell the company and the
CPG playbook is that at some point you
turn off the marketing. When is that?
Yeah. Um not anytime soon. Okay. So, you
just want you want to keep going for a
minute. Yeah. So, um, do you have a goal
like a billion a year in sales or I mean
a billion I'm very goal oriented so I do
have a billion on my whiteboard but I
recognize that before that I had a
million and before that I had 10 million
and then 100 million. So a billion will
be enough for sure. Yeah, totally. Then
it'll be enough. Yeah. Then I'll just
lay down my arms and walk away and then
you'll be happy. You know I'm just
messing around. Yep. Exactly. Um, yeah.
I would like I think running this to a
billion in revenue would be a lot of
fun. Uh I don't know how fast that's
going to be. Uh we've definitely learned
that it's it's it's gotten a lot harder.
Like as you grow you just lose people
and you know it's just harder. Yeah. 1%
on how many customers do you have right
now? Like 430,000. Yeah. So 1% on
430,000. It's like oh all of a sudden
that's just you know 4,300 customers
that we just have if we lose 1%. It's
like okay that's a decent amount of
customers. And you're like, well, if
it's 10% churn annually, and you said I
think you were keeping Well, 60 of your
one or something. No, I mean, our our
churn is like 3% a month, right? Yeah.
So, that's 30-ish% or whatever. Means
you have to sign up 12,000 people a
month before you stop treading water
just to chill. Just Yeah. Yeah. So, it's
like it's those numbers just kept going.
That's 400 a day. Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. 400 a day. So, while we're
talking right now, people are saying,
"Yeah, just like they're leaving.
They're leaving.
Yeah, they're falling out, right? Don't
leave people. Like, we have a great
product, dude. You have bacon for life.
What are we talking about? Yeah, you're
losing your for life offer. Yeah. Like,
I I really do love the um the lifetime
the lifetime offers. Um yeah, I have a
book that's coming out that talks about
this this particular offer structure.
So, um a lot of fun. Yeah, lifetime
offer. I people getting a box of meat um
seemed really magical. Like I was like,
wait, wait, this is going to show up.
It's going to be frozen. Like, I don't
trust it. So, uh, money back guarantee,
like no questions asked. We'll just
we'll just refund you. Let me let me
talk to some of the fears of business
owners around money back guarantees
because I talk about them a lot, too.
Um, what percentage of customers do you
get uh who ask for refunds on on like a
monthly basis? Oh gosh, I don't like so
small I don't even know the number,
right? And the conversion increase is
certainly worth having. For sure. For
sure. Also, like um you know, one of our
core values is being customer obsessed.
Yeah. like we actually want to deliver
you an amazing product, right? And so if
we fail at that, you should get your
money back. Um that's like and it's
like, well, I'm I'm worried about that.
Well, fix your product. Make your
product better. Like spend time
obsessing over your product and you
you'll do very well with money back.
It's like dollar per box and then also
like happiness per box, like on the
customer side, like your delight per
box. Totally. Yeah. I mean, it's all
about your well the the metric that is
commonly used is the net promoter score.
So, it's all about your satisfaction
with the and we're constantly asking
what's your NPS right now? Uh, it's like
a 63. That's great. Yeah. Yeah. We're
pretty happy with that. So, but there's
room for improvement. I mean, we we know
our issues. We want to we we want a
perfect experience every time. Yeah. And
when you're shipping multiple species,
you know, you 12 to 15. Do you do fish
now? Yeah, we do seafood. How did that
how did you get was that just a whole
another have to find another supplier?
Yeah, I mean we don't use any of that.
Um so basically we got going we'll go
all the way back. We we got going. We're
shipping out boxes. We're making $20 a
box. The influencer thing is working. We
get to about 6,000 subscribers. Okay.
And it was clear to me that we had no
idea what we were doing. It was like,
okay, we've been faking it. That's
great, but like we need somebody who
knows how to buy me. We need an adult
here. Um, and so again, I went to
LinkedIn, usually while on the toilet,
uh, and I reached out to, um, this guy
who lived in Boston and, um, ran meat
and seafood at one of these big grocery
chains, right? Uh, but he had retired.
Okay. And so I was like, interesting
background, let's talk. Yeah. Pulled him
out of retirement. And he came and
started purchasing meat and seafood for
us. Meat and then seafood. Yeah. And I
mean the saving my whole thing was okay
we're shipping 60,000 pounds of meat.
I've got all I have to believe is that
somebody can save me like 25 cents a
pound and this is like worth it. Right.
So um he came in and just he's like you
guys are paying this like second day.
He's like you guys are paying enough in
chicken breast that you could send
people three pounds instead of one
pound. Do you want me to do that? And
I'm like yeah that'd be good. Yeah. 25
cents was the target. and he was like,
"I can give you a buck and a half." And
you're like, "Totally." I mean,
multiples of his of his salary back. Um,
and you know, I think it's really
important to that you hire experts in
certain areas at the right time, but in
certain areas. Well, I want to so I want
to I want to hit on on the the meta part
of this, which is like, all right, like
the big the big turning points because I
like I like like what are those those
inflection points in the business? So,
it's like, all right, you switch from
raising money to pre-selling. That's pro
I feel like that's like setting yourself
up on the right path. Okay, so that was
number one. Number two, um, is you
realize this influencer thing has some
legs to it and then you go hardcore on
getting influencers. You also reverse
engineer somebody else's database, which
I highly recommend if you're trying to
reach out to people um, to find the high
like I call them HBTs, but uh, high
value targets like how do we how do we
find the HBTs and then and then grab
them. Okay, so you do that. um you have
a happy accident with free bacon that
ends up being a core component um of the
offer and then later um you turn on the
lifetime version of that and then you do
that across kind of horizontally across
the box. You obsess about gross margin
per box. So whatever your unit economics
are of the business, you got super dot
on that and just want to make every
single p every single penny count
because it you know you're on the same
side of the table figuratively as the
customer. you got experts um in at the
right times. The branding person up
front, the Omaha stakes guy, later the
meat purchasing guy um that all came in
at key points to like unlock, you know,
levels of profitability and growth.
What's what are some of the other ones
that that that might have been skipped
over in the Gez man that's good. Just
like boil it down in a good way. Um I
think working like so our backbone
today, we still don't own our backbone.
So, uh distribution, we don't do we
don't own our own farms. We don't own
our employing. No. Okay. I was um
because we believe that it's better to
work with partners. It's kind of like
the Toyota approach. Work with partners.
Hold them hold their feet to the fire.
Hold them to a tight speck. Uh have them
do things they're not doing for anyone
else, but trust that they know better
than me. I don't know anything about
farming. I don't know anything about
slaughterhouses. Like that's a bad place
for me to spend my time. Uh the only
piece of our entire backbone that we
control is dry ice. We have two dry
plants. Okay. Um and that's because if
you don't have dries, you can't ship a
box. Yeah. And so we were like, we
should It's like a great insurance
policy. Yeah. Everything else because
you lose that revenue goes to zero.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. That's everything
else is like not um I I don't think it's
worth us taking. And so and I think
that's like one common mistake in box
subscription companies, in overfunded
companies, and just with the
entrepreneurs in general. Yeah. You need
to you need to like own everything. you
need to control all of it. And uh that
has been a huge It's actually been a
huge um part of our success. Well, then
let's So, because I'm sure you've had
partnerships that didn't go well. Yep.
And you've obviously been really good at
building these relationships. So, to the
greatest degree possible, do you have
any kind of test for how
you judge a partner's ability to fulfill
on their promises before you've started
working with them? Because obviously,
you know, you're bringing a huge amount
of business. There's a significant risk
that you take on by having a, you know,
a partner do something bad. There's
obviously with food there's huge
liabilities of a whole, you know, a
whole state has rotten meat. It's like,
I mean, it's a it's more of a PR
nightmare. It took Chipotle years to to
to live down the salmonila issue that
they had as a micro example. Yeah. Um,
so I mean on the on the meat side, we do
robust safety audits and you like we're
not working with you unless we've done a
whole bunch of audits.
Um, on the other partner side, we're
generally trying to work with the best
best people, like best-in-class. So, you
just look at an industry and say, "Okay,
we we want to find okay, so of all the
different farms in the US that are
grass-fed, who's the biggest and the
best and you're just trying to do a deal
with them?" Yeah. I mean, you you you
try to balance like um helping small
farmers, right? Um and working with big
farmers because a small farmer might
have 50 head and we might need like
100,000 head, right? So we can't work
with 2,000 small farmers. We work with
we generally work with collectives that
then work with the farmers. So we're
working with that collective saying this
is what we want. This is our spec. This
is how we want it raised. And then they
go and find the farmers. Um, and again
it's like we don't want to be on the
ground. You know, I love meeting with
farmers and doing all that, but like I
that can't be what we do for inspecting
hooves is probably So it's like really
important to know what you're good at
and what you're not good at. And
anything that you're not good at,
including picking up the phone, 1100
times, like just don't do try to get
someone else to do it because you can't
I don't think you can build a business
unless you're feeling that flow and
you're feeling like really engaged. And
that can only be done in the the work
that you're really good at. You've been
really good at picking those people
though. So like what what's your
obviously there's the reputation of the
company, right? But like also you're
really good at picking like the Omaha
Stakes guy and the branding guy that you
picked out and even Nick who did those
first, you know, 1100 calls. Like
what do you what do you cuz it's it's an
uncanny trait like you've been really
good at it. Just I'm just like listening
to the story. I have you haven't
mentioned I'm sure there were some
horror stories but like um it seems like
you've had a huge amount of success and
I I feel like if I had had a different
entrepreneur in the chair I would have I
could I could totally hear the total
other side of the story. I went to a
couple partners early. What I learned is
you got to control everything if you
want you know like I've you know I mean
like I've heard that side and so you're
obviously better at picking partners
than most people. So like what do you
think about in trying to isolate like
this person will work? Yeah. I mean so
early on when you're talking about your
first employees um I I have this
analogy. I think I stole it from someone
but like uh building a company is like
hacking through the jungle with
machetes. And so you're just like
there's you're just dropped in the
middle of the jungle. You have a
machete. You're like uh I don't know
where we're going. Yeah. At that point
you need people who are just going to
hack day and night with you. like you
just and it's grit. Yeah. So, I'm
looking for athletes. I'm looking for
people who have failed at something. I'm
looking for people with a chip on their
shoulder, you know, daddy issues, all
that because I've got all that. So,
like, you know, I I want to, you know,
as all great men do,
I uh that's the type of person I want.
And then as you grow, uh you realize
that like, okay, we need some experience
here. And how do we get experience? One
thing, and this doesn't totally answer
your question, but one thing that we did
that was like I think pretty um I
thought was pretty smart is uh I called
it the barbell strategy. We hired people
like out of retirement. Okay. Because
they were so far along in their career.
Yeah. And we found that the middle like
so really young and really old worked
incredibly well. I would say personally
I've had a lot of experience with that
too. Yeah. And the middle is like
they're super busy. They've got kids.
They've got all these commitments. They
want this to be like the one mark on
their career. Yeah. The one career the
career like careerists rather than
people who want to do the work. Hunger.
Hunger. Yeah. It's interesting because
the people at the very beginning want to
work all the time because they want to
learn a lot. Y the people at the end
want to work because they have nothing
else to do and they want to in some ways
like give have their experience be used
like they want to be useful legacy,
right? And that both of those are
actually concentrated on the work itself
rather than the label ascribed to the
work. Totally. And everyone a lot of
times people in the middle are it's like
you're three years on my resume uh and I
want to you know just leverage this
brand. I need to go from director to VP
and then I need this and I need this and
and yeah we just found that people on
the ends were just like so grateful and
and so like my title obsession. Yeah.
Yeah. I hate it. My meat guy. I just
remember this uh dinner I was at and
it's like I my me guy and uh Blue
Apron's meat guy was there and Blue
Apron's meat guy is like 32 years old in
like skinny jeans and a nice vest and my
meat guy is this like grizzled like
65year-old is like who do you think's
buying chicken for cheaper? Yeah. Like
like my guy looks like meat. Yeah. Yeah.
Like Yeah. I mean, so um that has been
uh and and that is uh I don't really
like I don't really know what's happened
here. Like I I like to say like the the
business wanted to be something way
bigger than I expected. Interesting. And
I just honor that as like some of these
people just kind of fell into my lap. Um
but I I definitely my first company I I
knew people were off culture and I hired
them anyway. And this time around, we
wrote down our core values and we're
like, "Okay, this is what we're this is
what we're hiring for." Um, one of our
core values is relentless improvement.
And, uh, to your question about
partners, um, any partner you work with,
there's going to be problems. Sure. And
we're just not afraid to talk about
them. We do quarterly business reviews.
We're like, you know, auditing. We're
doing a whole bunch of stuff and telling
you what you're doing wrong so you can
fix it. Because most partners don't want
to like just they want to fire the
relationship or not not talk to you.
It's like no, let's just keep getting
better. Yeah. Like let's just get
better. Like we want to lock arms with
you and get you better and so we're also
because we're trying to build a
long-term thing like we're just locking
arms with partners and trying to just
move forward with them. Talk to me. So
given the the growth rate that you had
so it was like was it it was like 5
million was the first like or second
year I think of business, right? Yeah.
So we started in September of 2015 and
we did like 200 in the Kickstarter. We
did like 500 grand and then we did 5
million and then 33 million and then 105
million 220. Then COVID hit we went to
450. Yeah. And then you had what like 5
and then 500ish the next year. 450 550
550 570. Yeah. And then last uh two
years ago, so 2023 we went down for the
first year. Okay. which was pretty
heartbreaking for a team that you know
prides ourselves on growth. So talk to
me. So and then last year we started
growing again. Okay, that's good. So I
have I have two followups. So first one
is talk to me about rush rushing like
what's your because like you you grew
really fast. Yep. And then you and then
you were essentially flat for like
basically four years. Yeah.
So what's huh? So
what's how does your perspective on
where you want to take the company
affect how you run the company with
regards to growth's rate? Yeah. And like
rush around goals. Yeah. I like talking
about rush a lot because I think it's
where all mistakes happen.
And you grow really fast without the
intention of growing really fast. Yeah.
Which I find has happened to me multiple
times. Yeah.
Um, you know, I think that we, so we
grew, obviously, we grew incredibly
quickly. Um,
the biggest mistake that we made, the
biggest rush that we made was we um the
wheels kind of felt like they were
falling off the bus. Yeah. At like 450.
Okay. And we decided to bring in a whole
bunch of people. Mhm. to help like fix
the wheels. We need bodies. Yeah. We
need bodies. We need bodies and we need
managers. We need people in the middle.
The middle, right? Yeah. What was head
count? Just so I have context. What was
head count at that at at like I mean
going into CO we were 85 people. Uh so
doing 200 going into CO with a headcount
of 80. Yeah. Great. And then uh coming
like uh end of 21 we were at
like two like one maybe 1 160 and then
we got to a height of 240. Yeah. Uh with
designs on you know we're going to be
like 300 people. Yeah. And now I'm like
you know what like 150 sounds really
good, right? Yeah. So, um, yeah, we
currently have we have 25 associates in
our drives facility and then like 170
people outside of that. Um, and so the
rush was we hired a lot of people and
what what happens to companies and
apparently I've learned now that this is
a classic $500 million trap. So, you can
add a book to your your thing later. The
$500 million trap is something bad
happens. You hire a bunch of people
because you don't know enough and they
everyone starts saying no. Yeah. And you
go from um capital E entrepreneurship
like a bunch of pirates like very little
process. We're just going and growing
and like to like oh we need we need
process like we need capital P process
and entrepreneurship needs to come way
down here and that's what happened. You
guys are a bunch of kids. You're a bunch
of kids like you, Mike, are like, you
know, have all these ideas and like we
need to collaborate with you and Hey
guys, so if you're paying careful
attention, let me read what the stage of
scaling road map was at when he was
telling the stories about going from 80
to 180 plus employees. Does it sound
like uh recruiters are holding
inconsistent standards and the culture
suffered? Would you say that there were
so many new and existing employees,
performance suffers, compliance issues,
and complaints skyrocket? Would you say
that you're still paying retail for
everything? Right. and he's getting
overcharged. Cash is unprotected and not
getting good returns. Would you say that
was pretty indicative of exactly what he
was going through? Well, that's because
he was at the stage of specialize,
right? And so, the crazy thing is that
businesses behave in patterns. And so,
if you'd like to know what stage of
scaling you're at, you can go to
acquisition.com/roadmap. It's absolutely
free. It's our gift to you. We put a ton
of time and effort in this. It's
probably the biggest gift I can give
you. Um, and like I said, it's free. So,
go there, check it out. It'll tell you
exactly what you need to do to get to
the next level. and um enjoy it. And
that's what happened. And at the
meantime, I broke my arm. Like my
everything in my life kind of fell apart
at the same time. And uh it was it was a
slog. Uh and I'm I'm really proud. Like
last year we grew like 6%. And I'm like,
"Yeah, like we'll take it." Yeah. Um
and you know, so sometime along the
journey, um I went from like this is a
hobby to I'm going to just flip this
thing. like let me build this up and
sell it to for $100 million
and I went on a couple meetings and I
was like it just doesn't feel right.
Interesting. And then I I just it just
kind of over time came to me of um the
meat industry is broken. Yeah. Uh
animals are not being treated well in
this country and that's like hurting the
health of like people who are eating it.
And it's like I just wish there was a
company that like wasn't funded, had no
one breathing down their neck, who could
just take the play the long ball. Yeah.
And just like this might take 25 years,
might take a hundred years, but who
cares? Like we're in it for the long and
then after a while it was like after
pointing out everyone else who should be
doing that, it's like oh maybe that's
me. Yeah. Um and so I have no idea if
this is what's going to happen, but the
the plan is to build a
multi-generational long-term hold. Um,
if you look at food companies in the US,
many of them are family controlled,
multigenerational, long-term holds. Um,
and so that's kind of like that's how
I've built since the past few years.
Yeah. Uh, while reinserting myself and
becoming a becoming a pirate
organization again. Does it feel better?
Yes. Yeah. I mean, we um we did a lot of
work in the middle layer like a lot of
directors, a lot of Yeah. Yeah.
At our at our height, we had 230 people
and um 85 managers. Managers manager
managing manage manager managed to um 85
managers. So like the average person had
like one person underneath them. Yeah. I
just equated to um like the restaurant
worker where the receipt comes out and
they grab it and they're like where's
the chicken parm? Yeah. Yeah. On their
phone like chicken parm, you know? It's
like dude, what do you do all day? Yeah.
Um and so we've done a lot of work in in
like retasking people and just making
sure that people are in the right seats
doing things doing things and uh it it
feels much better. We're moving much
quicker. We're growing. We're Yeah. So
you're losing 12,000 customers a month.
Yeah. Something like that. Yeah.
How do you have any idea what the split
is of new customers per month in terms
of where the sources of customers come
from?
And is there a an acquisition channel
that you have not mentioned so far that
has that majorly contributes to that?
Yeah, so uh right now we're we're
heavily on referral and heavily on meta.
Those are like the two ads and refer
like meta ads and referrals. Ads and
referrals. Um, what's the split? Uh,
we're
like,
um, 30% referral. Okay. Uh, and then I
don't know what meta is because it's,
you know, there's also organic and
Google and whatnot. Uh, say 30% Meta and
20% organic. Yeah. Affiliate, all the
other channels, influencers are 10 or
whatever it is. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
referrals been really interesting. Uh we
now if you're a member you can uh refer
a friend for a trial box and it cost
$20. Mhm. Um and we've just seen that
work really well. Does the refer what
does the referer get? Uh nothing. Okay.
Yeah. Uh we tried a whole bunch of
different things that you get $50, you
get this, you get that. What they what
they like the most is giving their
friends a box that's almost free. They
just pay for shipping and handling. Oh,
so like a free plus shipping basically.
So it's like box is free. It's $20 for
shipping and handling kind of thing.
Exactly. Interesting. So that's another
offer. Yeah. Yep. And uh that's worked
really well like the you obviously get a
lot of people who just take get one box.
They're like sweet free meat and then
they cancel. But um you know executed
well you see a lot of people stay and
then they just become great customers
and yeah referrals are better customer.
Yeah if you like a referred customer is
a better customer. Um and so we've
really leaned into that as a program
because it compounds at scale which is
why it's so great. Yeah. Exactly. Um,
yeah, we've shipped a box to 1.7 million
1.75 million households in this country.
Um, and so at a certain point you're
like, how do we inspire those people to
do the sales on our behalf rather than
us trying to like, you know, retarget
people on Facebook? Yeah. So, um,
there's there's two com two things that
I wanted to get into. So, one is the ad
strategy and second is if I'm not
mistaken, you guys did a media play,
correct? Recently. Yep. Yeah. I want to
talk about that because I think that's
really cool. So, let's do media play
first. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. We bought a
company called Truffle Shuffle. Uh it's
these two two guys. Uh one's actually in
Vegas. We're going to see him tonight
for dinner. Um and they they raised
money on Shark Tank. And during CO, they
decided that they were going to sell
truffles direct to consumer. These
little mushrooms that are hard to get.
And then once they started selling
truffles, they realized that no one
knows how to cook them. Um and so they
started doing these instructional videos
like you have like DeJouro and I'm just
putting my shovel. Exactly. People are
like how do I what do I do with this?
Yeah. Uh and that took off and this is
like co where um everyone's at home
trying
to all these corporations are trying to
like you know uh treat their staff well
and stuff and whatnot. So um yeah so
they they ran a pretty interesting
business for a while. great content,
thousands of classes where they're
teaching people how to cook and live.
Uh also recorded but live. Um and they
just like that they're experts ato
hosting a live class to cook. Yeah.
Virtual. Virtual. Yeah. Our biggest
challenge as a company, if you look at
our churn, the people who are leaving,
our biggest challenge as a company is
how do I inspire you to take the meat
out of your freezer? Yeah. Yeah. They
put it in there and they're like, "Oh,
I've got two months worth. Like, I don't
need any." Right. And people think of
their freezer as like a savings account
rather than a like And so when you say,
"What's for dinner?" You open your
fridge. Yeah. And look inside or you
look on your phone and or something. So,
how are we going to like inspire you?
Well, one way to do that is if we do
cooking classes. Mhm. So, we um you
know, really like the founders, Jason
and Tyler, and just uh decided that it
was a good fit. We got it for you know,
like a good price, which I don't think I
could talk about, but Yeah. And uh we
ended up ingesting them. And so now
we're doing cooking classes for our
members. We're doing And that's included
in the subscription. Yeah. Included in
the subscription. Do you do So how much
of it is public and like available for
people who are not buyers? We're trying
to figure that out. Okay. Um cuz I'm so
like cuz I don't know how big of a media
company in terms of like you know
impressions they do but like it cuz my
whole my whole my whole business model
around content is just demonstration
right it's just like show don't sell.
Yeah. And then the selling will occur.
Yeah. Um and so like whenever you have
the opportunity in my opinion that's the
that's the most elegant you know way of
of selling. Yes. Um, and so like these,
you know, high-end chefs having these
really engaged high-end, you know, I
mean, obviously Yeah. Right. Yeah.
They're highend. Yeah.
Um, I because on one level there's the
retention piece. Um, but I have this
theory around the idea
that so I think this is this I don't
have a double blind placebo test here,
but this is Alex's opinion. Um, I think
that you retain customers that pay for a
subscription with free content that's
available for everyone for a couple
reasons. Number one, a lot of people
don't log into stuff. It's just like
you're not like, "Oh, I'm going to go
log in. What's my password?" And then
it's already you're already like gone.
It doesn't it's not going to happen. So,
the reason that I have like all my
courses on my site are all free and also
available with no login is for that
purpose. And it's certainly been a
significantly better thing than me
trying to hide it behind even an opt-in
wall uh just to collect people's emails.
Um you can watch them and then at the
halfway point or whatever it just says,
"Hey, you can opt in if you want. You
can also not opt in and keep watching
the video." Yeah. Um and it's been
exceptional for lead generation and um
so the thing one is that uh I I don't
think a lot of I think the utilization
is not as high as I would like it to be.
Um even when you make these really
high-end things. The second is that it
certainly doesn't drive I think that you
will drive more not you but like one
anybody can drive more sales with making
the media available to everyone. It also
makes it more sharable. Um and I think
that spins the referral machine. You get
the media machine from platforms. Um and
then that will drive top offunnel sales
and awareness. Um and I think that maybe
you put a handful of them behind a pay
wall if you want to as a as a membership
benefit. I'd be curious to know if
because if we're thinking about like how
do we solve the problem? Sorry, this is
me like like how do we solve the problem
of the customers I have bank too much
meat and don't cook it because they're
not inspired enough to cook. So it's
like okay so we want we're trying to
maximize on consumption in two ways.
Consumption of meat but consumption of
meat cooking so that it leads to
consumption of meat. Yep. Right. And so
if you were to pre-educate, right, where
people watch some show about some
truffle meat dish and then purchase,
they're purchasing with intention to
make a specific dish. And I think it's
almost like it it like colors them a
different type of customer because their
consumption experience was preframed
with recipes versus I'm going to buy
meat because this is good quality meat
and it's a good deal and I'm getting
free bacon. Um, just this is me just I'm
totally spitballing here, but like that
was that was that was when Harley told
me that you bought that media business,
that was immediately where I guessed or
where where I thought you were going to
go. I was like, "That's that's
brilliant." Yeah. Good. Well, push as
much of that as humanly possible out.
Incorporate the product into everything.
Way more eyeballs come in. Existing
customers still attribute the benefit of
their
subscription to the show because they're
still going to consume the meat, right?
And so you still get the the the
positive brand association even if it's
free for other people, right? And that
was something that actually like I I
stumbled upon that. So because I've I've
had media businesses, right? And um
there's always this big fear in anything
media related, especially if you have
memberships and things behind pay walls,
that what if I give away too much for
free that I upset my paid customers. But
I I in in my experience, it hasn't been
the case at all. one because basically
no one logs into anything. Um as big,
you know, big thing, you know, big point
number one. Um but secondarily that I
think the human brain has a very hard
time uh attributing whether the content
they watched was behind a payw wall or
not behind a payw wall. I think we zoom
out and say has Butcher Box provided
$129 of value to me this month. And you
think about the one meal that you
cooked, whether from a recipe that you
found, whether it was your recipe that
was behind a payw wall and not in behind
a pay wall or just that they saw on a
cooking show and used your meat, right?
That wasn't even associated with the um
the truffle hustle. Is that what it was?
Truffle shuffle. Truffle shuffle. Yeah.
Yeah. Um and so anyways, that's that's
my that's genius. Two cents. Yeah,
that's more than two cents probably.
That was probably worth more than two
cents. I'll come back in a couple years
and we'll, you know, I'll cross off the
billion. Still won't be enough. But uh
yeah, I mean that's um that that's the
beauty of owning content is uh pushing
it out more, doing more serving our
member. But I think um that gives me a
lot to think about terms of like how are
we pushing it to non-members because
we've we've definitely been careful.
We've been like well this should be a
benefit for our members. Yeah. I would
just I'd be curious because I think that
because there would be because the math
problem right is is solvable of does the
increase in conversion and retention on
members with this added benefit which
I'm sure you've measured like now that
we added in the box has it measurably
reduced churn or has it measurably
increased conversion rate on the page
whatever um versus the amount of new
customers that come in with first second
third touch point via content. Yeah. And
it my bet would be that you would this
is my bet obviously I don't know but my
bet would be that it'd be more on the on
the top end and then from the ads ads
perspective because I know you run a ton
of advertising I'm sure um it's like I
feel like that kind of content taking
the because if if you have it public
then you can let the algorithm tell you
which pieces are the the fire fire
pieces of content um of the cooking and
then push that out. Yeah. as top ofunnel
awareness ads, you know, retarget people
who are at, you know, do 50%, 75%,
whatever it is. Um, with now your
conversion stuff, but they have positive
brand sentiment because like now they're
like they're in they're in the market,
you know what I mean? They just consume
this. They're literally they were
watched enough to be inspire they were
inspired enough to watch and so now we
just want to see if they're inspired
enough to buy.
Love it. Just love it. Yeah. There's uh
there's a book called How Brands Market
and what they what they found was they
put up all these ads like billboards and
stuff trying to get new customers, but
they found that it actually drove more
repeat orders. Um and so that's similar
like if we if we put out content to the
they'll be reminded to eat their meat.
That's right. Right. Is that Yeah, I
think that I think it's brilliant and I
think that like I'm really excited to
see what you do with it. How long ago
was the acquisition? Uh we bought it in
June of last year or something. Okay. So
it's really still pretty recent. Yeah.
Uh we just launched a spice line with
them. We've done a bunch of uh social
content. Um but yeah, I think um you
know making more of it public would
probably be a good thing. Yeah, I think
be interesting. Um and so uh the the the
last piece was the ad strategy for
Facebook. So what do you what's been
your thinking process for generating
probably the amount of creative I'm
assuming? I mean, you've got a pro I
mean, yeah, you probably have to put out
50 pieces a day in order to maintain
that kind of and you probably have
gotten a crash course on running ads if
you're the CEO of this business. Yeah.
Um, so we've we've gone all sorts of
different ways. Uh, we have, um, had ad
agencies work on our stuff. Um, so buy
our ads and, you know, update and
whatnot. We've done in in-house. We've
gone back and forth. Uh, we're currently
outsourced to our ad buying.
Interesting. Um, outsource media buyers.
Who does the creative? Uh, they do as
well. They do the creative. Yeah, we do.
We do sell some. We give them
guidelines, but they do it. The reason
why was we weren't moving fast enough.
Um, so it had become, as you said, Yeah.
become a game of it's like an arms race.
You got to like be changing your
creative all the time. And we um we
noticed that there were multiple
multiple multiple meetings to like talk
about and obsess about all these things.
It's like we this this isn't going to
work. We can't do this. So, we you know,
we made a hard pivot. Um, I imagine at
some point we'll come we'll be like,
"Okay, we're paying way too much. We
need to like do it in house." But the
speed, do they charge a percentage of ad
spend? Is that Yeah. But so when you're
spending a lot, that's a lot of money.
Yeah. Um, and that's baked into CAC.
That's baked into the CAC. Yeah. Yeah.
Um, have you you have you done multiple
different agencies over time or is it We
have I mean there are certain agencies
that work well at a smaller size and
certain ones that work at a bigger size.
Uh we have we haven't been able to grow
with like one agency. Okay. Um you've
had multiple at Yeah. at different
times. Uh where we've inst we have one
right now. It's not like you have four
running for you. Yeah. Got it. Okay. Um
and cuz I had a buddy who had a really
big company and he had four different
agencies working at the same time and he
was like yeah the world's big all I need
all of them just fully focused. And I
was like, are you worried about like you
know like well yeah it's and that was
the kind of the response was just like
well there's 300 million Americans like
I'm not giving them no one's getting any
other access besides like pixel traffic
and so they can make their own look
likes off of whatever they think is
going to going to convert and if there
is some overlap there's probably overlap
with 10 other thousand companies that
are also advertising and so it's more
because I think the deficit like the the
constraint is more the creative power
and mental mental bandwidth and
attention and skill
than um than really anything else. And
so like one like one team and you
probably know this from the from from
the companies or at least you've
experienced this the same way I have. Um
there's this law I can't remember what
it is. Tom Billy talked about it but he
basically the square root of every
company does 50% of the value creation.
So it's like you have 100 employees 10
people will do 50% of the value
creation. Yeah. And I I like I thought
about it I was like that sounds about
right. um in terms of like where's the
the contribution towards revenue and all
that kind of stuff. And so when you
think about that from from the from the
the agency owner perspective, it's like
I'm getting these four really good
people from this agency on my stuff, but
I also want the four really good people
from this company and the four really
good people from this company. So it was
just like a interesting thing. So you
have you've have one agency that runs
all of it. They're doing I can't believe
they're do they're doing really
everything. So how like they're going
out? I mean we do some stuff internally,
but they're going to like So they're
like going to farms and capturing stuff.
No, we have all that B-roll. Like we
have B-roll. We have all that. Um, so
they're not they're not really taking
any they're not going all the way
shooting. We have all that content. Um,
and uh, yeah, I mean, I think
um, Facebook has been a wild place for
the past few years. It's like either
working really well or not working at
all. We've also had more competitors
come into our space. You know,
everyone's copying us. Yeah. everyone's
advertising against us, which I think is
a good thing, but it's like here's why
we're better than Butcher World, you
know, and it's it's a different world.
Um, and you know, I think there's been a
lot of conversation about this on
Twitter recently around like, um,
Facebook is great for retargeting.
Somebody comes to your website, True,
great. Um, top of the funnel, a little
bit harder. Top of the funnel meaning
like you're you're exposing your brand
to new eyeballs. Um, that's where I
think, you know, in order to grow from
to just continue the growth, which we
have to do, we have to have 12 to 15,000
people a month, like at least. Yeah. Um,
we just need a lot more top of the
funnel awareness. And one of the
challenges I've had is uh driving top of
the funnel awareness has been really
hard. What makes sense for the media
acquisition? That's why I like the house
like brilliant. Yeah. Yeah. Um, so we've
we've done other things like we've we've
tried to do a lot of like brand top of
the funnel stuff that has not worked.
I'm hopeful in the media thing. Um, but
really we're trying to like get the word
out about what we're doing. We're trying
to change the industry. Um, but the uh
Yeah, Facebook has been I I mean you
could see it in our numbers. We were
like grow grow and then there was the
iOS change in 2021. It's just like Yeah.
And then inflation. Yeah. I mean Yeah.
made for business is easy. Yeah. It's
super easy. Super easy. Do it. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I think that like um
focusing on the fundamentals is so
important for people. Uh like you broke
down the business into like these
moments and fundamentals along the way.
And um you know, yeah, business is hard.
It can be really challenging, but if you
just focus on the things that matter and
know the things that matter, um it can
be a lot easier. And I think oh a big
this is me just saying from outside
perspective I think a big part of the
success has also been that like you
haven't had a mental option for pulling
the rip cord you know um and so when
problems come it's like well we're I'm
not going anywhere so you just kind of
take it one bite at a time you know and
I think that when you when it's almost
like u in a marriage if you like if
divorce is an option in your mind then
maybe you don't feel like having the
conversation it's like you you're like
you know but screw this, right? Um, but
if it's just never an option and you're
just like, I'm I'm in, right? Under that
hypothetical guys or premise, then it's
like that's the that's the premise that
you approach all the problems within the
business is like, well, I either die or
we keep going. So, we keep going. I'm
still alive. Therefore, we will solve
these problems one at a time. Yeah. Um,
yeah, it is really interesting with the
top of funnel component. Um, I feel like
I feel like the content is the ultimate
is the ultimate top funnel because it's
the that you know you can harness the
algorithm finding all those people
because it'll serve the your meat stuff
to the people who really want meat.
Yeah. And you don't have to figure out
what like the perfect lookike audience
is like they'll do that. Yeah. And then
then you have this massive retargeting
audience where you can spend the amount
of money you're spending now, but it's
all warm traffic because you're getting
a billion impressions a month on uh on
all this all this content being pumped
out, which I think is so cool. I think
it's I think it was just a brilliant
acquisition. Thank you. So, no, I'm I'm
pumped to see it. Well, um I think I can
say on behalf of uh all the
entrepreneurs who listen to the game,
thank you so much for sharing uh the
story of Butcher Box. Busher Box to a
Billy uh and beyond. Um but thanks so
much, man. Appreciate it. Thank you.
Appreciate it. No. Hey guys, I hope you
enjoyed this uh conversation that I had
with Mike. I pretty much just led this
as what I wanted to know uh about
ButcherBox. And hopefully if you're
anything like me, uh you just want to
know the business stuff. And so I make
all of this content for business owners.
And if you like this style of
conversation, going deep, breaking down
the business, showing some of the
lessons, the failures along the way, but
really getting tactical, um let me know
in the comments. Uh, and I'll I'll do
more of it. And if you were like, "Hey,
this blows."